Let's take a look at keeping customers for the web/mobile channel.
Web/mobile works almost exactly like physical channels--keeping customers.
It's exactly the same idea--we might want to offer loyalty programs, contests and events,
blogs, RSS and email, or social media--all designed to engage customers.
Why do you want to think about keeping customers is that customers are
a lot more expensive to acquire over here than they are to keep.
And the key thing that you want to worry about is churn or sometimes called customer attrition.
And here is why--so imagine if you are losing 5% of your customers a month,
well in 3 years you'll only have about 16% of them left, but imagine if you can reduce churn to 1%,
so that every month only 1% of these customers left.
After 36 months with 1% attrition, you'd have 70% of your customers left.
Just think about it, with 5% attrition, your average customers sticks around for about 20 months,
but with 1% attrition, they stick around for 100 months.
You get 5 times more revenue from the same customers by just working
on keeping these customers around.
Now, by the way in reality, financial people discount the cash flows
from customers later in this life cycle.
The actual value you get is somewhat less--how much less depends on your industry
and cost of capital, but we'll leave that for the accounting to set in a more detailed price